Hello Freak bitches. I've,
I mean, I did. I did one,
I did Jimmy Fallon once seeding the Jimmy
Fallon and every organization wanting
to get me, what'd you say?
I was doing a joke, uh,
of singing. We were singing these
funny songs about who let the dogs out.
And so we took who let the dogs out
and put it in like a, um, like a,
like a Vaudeville or show tune who left
the dogs or whatever it was. Right.
But beginning of that,
I sort of ad libbed like I was watching
these dogs and they were coming towards
me and I was wondering,
you know,
who let them out and there was
a pit bull there and you know,
you have to be careful because pit bulls
can be contained, curious, you know,
and then I go into the song,
the pit bull community,
it was like Jamie Foxx session
pitbull Seamus, you pit bull shit.
And then there was another thing
where Jimmy Fallon was doing, um,
was doing some type of, uh, he was saying
what was going to be in the next show.
And I was doing a bad version of signing,
which I actually know how to sign,
but I was doing a bad
version of sign language.
I know sounding like we'll talk
more about it later, you know,
all those types of different things.
But as I was doing it as a joke,
I didn't know that the person that he
was talking about happened to be deaf.
Okay.
Oh No. Oh my God. And so then, you know,
so it was just all of these things.
And I tried to tell people, I said,
hey, listen, we never mean anything bad.
We poke fun, but we're not, we don't
mean anything bad, but you can't just,
you know, he can't, you can't kill us.
I, and I cause I to keep doing what I do,
you know? So it's, it's getting tougher.
Well, it's just what we were
talking about, about social media,
about people commenting on things
that you can't read the comments.
There's just too many people and people
are always looking for something to be
recreationally outraged that
in the comments to get that
ass through the comment,
comment and hit you right where
you are sometimes good. Damn.
This motherfucker's right.
Well it's good to though a little bit.
You went there right?
When they're actually right.
Like someone could say something
ridiculous about you and you know it's
ridiculous. It doesn't mean anything,
but if it's got a hint of truth,
but when somebody says
something about your teeth, you,
you kind of look in the mirror. I don't
understand it. Like I'm fucking, I got,
but I got somebody hit me with the donkey,
then you know it's fucking donkey.
I was like, ah. I start
talking like, yeah,
I didn't know if I give it a so you know,
but I tell people all the time,
don't read the comments.
That's the book.
Don't read the comments because it will
make you start to change the way you do
things. If I read all the comments,
I never tell another joke. Yeah.
If I read all the comments, I'll
never try another, you know,
I got a movie that we just a shot for
little or nothing called all star weekend
and the jokes are like all
the way out there, you know,
and I got everybody in it,
you know, and we're all taking
all played different characters.
Like I play a white
racist white racist cop.
And how do you do that?
Awesome. I'll show it to you. I'll
grab it, I'll grab the thing, show tea.
But it's a, uh, Robert
Downey jr he plays a Mexican,
a Gerard Butler plays a Russian
who loves gymnastics. Uh,
Benicio del Toro plays this crazy
tattoo artist and we're all, you know,
we're all doing our thing.
So it's like if you read the comments,
that'll make you tuck that in. But this
is some brilliant and, and it's, it's,
it's a cool little thing to, it's, it's
called a all star weekend for a reason.
It's about two guys.
One guy loves Steph curry,
the other guy loves Lebron James and all
they're trying to do is get to the all
star game.
And it's sort of like this whole journey
of running into all these people.
So it's dope. But it is some things
where it's like, Ooh, you know,
you can see there's going to be some,
some shit gone.
But Robert Downey jr just from
tropic thunder, think about that.
You could never do that anymore. You
cannot blackface anymore. You know what?
I'll say this, people have to
understand where it comes from.
There are real people that did it
really mean you harm like outside of us.
I mean there's some real people
who really don't fucking like you.
Whatever you are, whether you're black,
you're white, you're straight, you're gay,
whatever it is.
There's some people who really don't
with the entertainment and it's easy.
We're easy.
Targets were easy.
It's easy for you to jump on Robert Downey
jr or Jamie fives or Joe because it's
easy. You know, when it's
real things, which you know,
whether it's politics or whether it's
whatever. A lot of times we, we SORTA,
we're not ready for that fight, but
it's easy to sort of pick the comedian.
I called Robert. I said, listen, I need
you to play a Mexican. He says, dude,
here's the deal. Sure, sure. Why not?
Fuck it. Sure. Of course, no Mexican,
whatever.
But then he texts back and said,
I'm nervous to play the
Mexican. And I said, well shit,
you played the black dude and you killed
that shit. We're just all, you know,
we gotta be able to do character.
What kind of blow back did you get
from playing the black dude? None.
Because we first go for the
wire too though. It was like,
what year was tropic thunder? I feel like
I was like 10 years ago. It was wow. But,
but, but here's the thing,
we fuck with Robert Downey
jr like that's my guy, right?
Like I did his birthday party and my
first joke was how dare you take all of
these roles from black people, you know?
Anyway, everybody's laughing. Have we got,
so it's Sorta like the entertainers,
man. We sh we, you got to give us room.
You know what I'm saying? Like to
play any, I'll show you when I,
when I to take that room, you got to
take it. You can't worry about it.
I saw the Chappelle
somewhere. It was like, no.
They would ask him about his jokes and
he was like, Yo man, look, you know,
people have said we're a shit.
And I think he said something about Donald
Trump's saying grab them by the Pussy
or some shit, whatever. But it was
true. It was like the one thing
that you look at what happened
with politics this year,
people sort of stripped away a lot
of things. You know what I'm saying?
Regardless of what you
believed in, uh, who,
whatever person you voted for,
it was a lot of things that
we'll sorta addressed about,
like maybe we're playing
things a little too close.
Like some of those politicians were
afraid to say what Donald Trump was saying
and they ended up being left in the dust
because people were a little like, whoa.
Well,
he's,
he's got a point in the sense of we're
playing things a little too close.
Okay.